Kimora Lee Simmons says no no to this
fashion faux pas even if it comes from
one of her little ones it's a rare
moment a rare sighting well New York
Fashion Week might be wrapped but one
front row moment is going viral
that's the provoc show two weeks ago
where Kimura stepped out with daughters
Ming and Aoki and wanted her kiddos to
get the most of their A-list views 869
girls wanna drink wine tell them man not
to waste your time the Mind broke the
man here jokes
yeah cabora's scolding Ming for being on
her phone while sitting front row three
six nine girls wanna drink wine tell the
man not to waste your time the Mind
broke the man he a joke so you gotta get
loose but Kimura is not embarrassed of
the mother-daughter moment as she tells
it in the Instagram caption a mom's
gonna mom and in her story happy Monday
I'm the type that sends those texts that
are like happy Monday but the next day
Aoki made mom proud on the other side of
the catwalk strutting in the Sergio
Hudson show it's like how they were
basically born on the runway walking
down the runway with me Yep this comes
nearly 20 years after the sisters made
their Runway debut helping Mom launch
the iconic baby fat fashion brand I
think that's how people remember us
walking down the runway and the girls
were little and now they're big and can
do their own runwaying fast forward to
2023 the nepo baby discourse is
everywhere but we should note Ming's
going to NYU as she builds her
influencer Empire and when aoki's not
striking a pose she's attending Harvard
I have this concept that I've talked
about a lot throughout my life which is
that I don't want to raise kids that are
a-holes and
and they're not they're good kids
they're beautiful kids and I think that
oftentimes women aren't
um
expected to have it all or young women
and I think that goes especially for
women of color I think a lot of times
but definitely women as a whole I think
a lot of times they weren't we weren't
expected to have it all like who said
you could have brains and Beauty we're
business women too that's what's
underneath I have an Empire I'm turning
over to my kids and they gotta make sure
to know how to yeah run that and and
they support me and I support them and
it doesn't matter what you look like but
you look great but it matters what's up
here but to learn and acquire knowledge
and grow no one can take that away from
you yeah the kids seem pretty grown up
but they'll never be too old to get
words of wisdom from Mom three six nine
girls when I drink wine tell them not to
waste your time
all of these things are very
small price to pay for being given you
know something so great
[Music]